most of the papers leading today on that  cia report into torture jack straw  denied that there's been any complicity  from britain and will be probably pretty  relieved that libya was hardly mentioned  in the report given the claims about  rendition that they've been in the past  david cameron's also waded in and  condemned what happened today talking  about schools the chief inspector uh  ofsted saying that secondary schools  aren't improving fast enough department  for education kind of  rejected it really and said that they  disagree that things are going well but  clearly it's a big criticism and action  will need to be taken we're also  expecting pmq's today but not with the  prime minister because he is visiting  auschwitz so it's nick clegg versus  harriet harm and i wonder what she will  decide to go on today maybe child abuse  given the problems with the inquiry or  maybe she'll stick to her leader's  favorite subject and try and go on  health